Joined by Derrick Williams from DW Science desk and Martin Gak from our Religion and Ethics department.
Welcome to both of you. Let me start with you Derrick.
Now first of all. How short can we be of this claim made by the scientists that he's genetically edited babies,
because there's been no independent scientific verification so far has there?
No, there hasn't been there. This hasn't followed the normal past.
Generally, you would have had a publication with peer-review first of all, before it,
but this researcher has made basically a claim online. And as of now, we don't have any real hard evidence to back it up.
Although he does have the background, and he does have the experience to have carried it out.
But turning it to you, this scientist insists that what he's done with these babies
is to protect them from a condition in this case HIV.
So he's actually says he's protecting them. What's wrong about that?
Well at first blush obviously nothing. I mean one would think this is quite commendable.
But the fact is that this is a technology that is sort of at it's very incipient stage, and furthermore,
the problem is that there is absolutely no way to measure what the impact of
any one, sort of, gene editing operation will be.
I mean, bear in mind that you would be releasing these people into the population.
Provided that they grow up and, these two, these twins actually reproduce and have children of their own.
They will actually be perpetrating this genetic format, I mean, bringing it into the genetic pool.
Evidently, we don't know, if this has actually taken place or not, but to judge by the reaction of the international
scientific community, I think we can assume that everybody understands that this is a possibility.
A serious possibility that this scientist is capable of doing, it and I think he's correct,
in saying that if it's not him, it's imminent that this is gonna happen.
So, a lot of the questions here, as far as I'm concerned, is about, once again regulation.
How are we gonna regulate this kind of technology?
So you have some serious ethical concerns about this, but what about you Derrick as a scientist?
Well, I agree completely.
The technology is there, but it's been there actually for the last eight years,
and it's been clear that we could use this technology to do this.
We haven't up until now. We've been doing mostly things with plants, with animals,
but the possibility has always been open.
People have been, that's why it's been a taboo. Things only become taboo when they become possible,
and this is definitely become a possibility.
And so the question is now, I think, what we need to be moving towards,
both the scientific community and the world as a whole, is global regulation of this kind of technology.
But are we really, it's not no more than at a national level. Where things are possibly allowed,
as is the case in China within certain guidelines.
Or they're at least not completely forbidden, whereas in other places, they might be.
I think it's worth pointing out that...
Nobody should think that this is something this big can be pulled back.
I mean, if as a matter of fact this technology is there, and it's being used,
there is no way that this will stop being used because we actually think it shouldn't.
I mean, this is precisely why we need international regulations,
because the technology is already there and it's usable.
The thing about regulation is that often the boundaries
between scientific discovery and ethical concerns are sometimes blurred.
So how does one regulate this kind of development?
I think that this is becoming, it's not sometimes blurred, more and more often that technology and ethics
are coming into conflict with one another. We need, and we obviously from from my point of view.
We need to to answer most of the ethical concerns,
or many of the ethical concerns, before we begin to employ the technology in certain ways.
Unfortunately, it generally tends to happen in the other direction.
Yeah, very clearly. I mean.
I think that what we actually find in the scientific discourse and the scientific tradition,
and the way that we implement technology, because bear in mind,
that most people out there in the world will actually see science through technical developments.
I mean some somebody will want to get pregnant, not be able, and then they will find a scientific development
in in vitro fertilization or something like that. This kind of things tend to happen in precisely a door there
It's like we engage in certain practices, and then we think okay, is this the best way?
Or do we actually need to put different forms of, you know, different controls?
At this stage, I think that element here is that it has a certain macabre aspect
and there is something Frankensteinian about this story.
Somebody had that has somehow concocted a human being.
I think that that's this disingenuous, I mean, it just helps to actually blur the problem.
Which is that as a matter of fact that we have a very powerful technology.
We don't have a very clear understanding of where it could lead.
What it could mean, but it is something that for us could be actually an incredibly powerful tool.
So, we have a responsibility.
Sorry, we have a responsibility to make good use of it so to say.
Derrick you yourself are a specialist in biology, and you know that this area of genetic science
is very very competitive with scientists looking at ways to outdo each other.
How do you see this when you see this? Where do you see this development going?
Because as a scientist said in our report, "If not me somebody else would have done it."
I think that that's probably true.
I also think, that you can't throw the baby out with the bathwater, if you'll excuse me in this particular instance,
CRISPR Cas9 technologies is an incredibly powerful tool for doing a wide, wide range of things.
Including doing things like providing plants with drought resistance.
We're able to go in and tinker with evolution
and things that might have taken many many generations to happen in the past.
We can now make happen very very quickly and very very easily.
But just because we can make them happen, doesn't mean that we should,
particularly when it involves the human race, and possibly the future of humanity.
Right. So the implications are huge, both on the ethical front as well as on the scientific front.
Derek Williams from our Science desk, and Martin Gak our Religious and Ethics Affairs correspondent.
Thank you very much for your perspectives.
You're welcome.